speaking of
kind of naughty words going blue yeah i
have to read you there is a song
that is i'll just bust out your glasses
i wish
excuse me sir now that we're going blue
so there's a new song that's taken over
the world
and when i say taking over the world i
mean like this is the story
okay this is like the story yeah so
i don't even know you know i don't go
blue on my show yeah i don't know
clean clean cut i don't wear socks in my
loafers you know i try to be
i can't say the name of this of this
song without going blue
would it be better and you're hosting
right now so i want you to do what you
think is right would it be right or if
if i just read it straight up i would
feel much better if you
so the song is called whap okay
right it's by cardi yeah w.a.p
okay it's by cardi b and this song i
mean this is like at the now the the
anthem the feminist anthem right and
cardi b
i'm not totally sure who she is but i
know she was like fighting with people
right before i went
yes she she supported bernie sanders
long nails i think she and i think
that's racist for you to say that but
yes she does have long skills
so here's so this is this song has just
taken over everyone's this is everyone's
taken over
so i'll just i guess i'll just read a
little yeah [ __ ]
in this house there's some [ __ ] in
this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
hole up i said certified freak
seven days a week wet ass [ __ ] make
that pull out game week
that's good and then the chorus yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you [ __ ] with some sweet ass
[ __ ]
bring a bucket and mop for this [ __ ]
mop
for this oh bring a bucket and mop for
this sweat
you got to mop up give me everything you
got for this wet ass
[ __ ] uh i'm gonna not do the next
paragraph because that's where they'll
come for me
yeah this is the so so where does she
get her mop
yeah you can't that's got some words
that you're not allowed to you know yeah
yeah
so that song i mean she's making a point
it's not she's making not without
merit no it's not it actually i th the
song
actually does have a point the thesis of
the song okay
is that all women are prostitutes
that's actually the thesis she says yeah
i got my man by
and she describes sexual acts that i
know look we're young hip millennials
okay we've done also
like that you've never thought of i mean
in this kind of
it's i didn't know that pornography
having a slot bucket when you're
it's like just that image i didn't know
that
that audio could be pornographic i
thought pornography is only visual yeah
so she's saying that these things are
good like this is how you attain power
in essence it's not yes
it's right she's not which is so the
root it's so the reverse
actually of what what at least first
wave feminism
was all yeah yeah it's it's a it's funny
because it's such a ridiculous song but
it is a commentary on our map
i see and it then it hits you it took me
like a day to i thought oh
as i'm pondering this deep song of great
singing yeah
and but that's it that and so to say
that calling women prostitutes and
having them sell themselves
is empowering is is obviously a complete
reversal of reality like you say reality
is on trial
it's emblematic to me of everything
that's going on another example do you
know bella thorne have you ever heard of
bella thorne
she's some movie star or she was she was
a tv star something like that okay
what was she into she i don't know
something like it wasn't going with the
wind i tell you okay it wasn't the
godfather okay
bella thorne goes on onlyfans.com
onlyfans.com is this way to democratize
porn
anyone can go on it and she does it and
she sells nude photos
some hacker hacks into her stuff takes
the nude photo she says well i'm gonna
just sell it
200 a pop 200 a pop for a nude photo on
the internet that's outrageous
she makes million bucks in the first day
two million bucks within the week
but i guess the photos were not
sufficiently nude so then the customers
were demanding a refund from only fans
that became a bigger
so then only fans stopped so they don't
know what they're buying no
they don't know they knew it was a nude
photo but you know it's all blurry or
something
and so they get the photos they want
they demand the reason they didn't see
the lap
they didn't they didn't get the whap
card would be very dismayed yeah
and so now only for instance in the
whole problem
they they make a cap it's only 50 now
per nude photo
and now the prostitutes on only fans are
very upset
because they previously were able to get
a lot of money for their photos
and they'll show the web because they'll
show the web and they figured i'd get
300 400 i don't know i don't know what
they charge yeah
bella thorne issues an apology to the
pornographers and the prostitutes
because she drove down their business
and it just occurred to me
every single person in this situation
did the wrong thing
isn't that a beautiful thing when
everyone can screw up something so
perfectly it's actually kind of
miraculous yeah
so she because she didn't show in effect
the wow
apologizes to the people who show the
whap only fans
drops the price the cap yeah
so that she ca so that basically she
can't blow the those guys out of the
water so to speak as it were
and now well this is you know i think
we're mixing metaphors but they are
creating a lot of images yes
and lest you think that a movie star
who's already a millionaire
going on and trying to make another
quick couple million by becoming a
pornographic actress
yeah unless you think the whap unless
you think all of that is
the bottom of our sexual decay yeah
what's the last sexual taboo in the
world
especially at least in our country
what's the last episode you shouldn't
bang a goat
are you sure how dare you yeah how dare
you shouldn't bad
i don't want to i'm not holier than now
but don't bang it look at me i'm no
bible thumbs yeah but
yeah it would seem to me i mean maybe
the goat thing is still a little taboo
yeah the last thing is kids right yeah
kids the most insane leftists
again i would think even the most insane
leftists say kids are off limits
wherever this is going wherever we're
going right now
netflix i'm not talking about some
crazy website in the depths of the
internet i'm not i'm not talking about
jeffrey epstein's plane
netflix posts a movie
it's called cuties and the picture the
poster is
of 11 year olds pre-teens
twerking and here's the description
amy 11 becomes fascinated with a
twerking dance crew
hoping to join them she starts to
explore her femininity
defying her family's traditions
i'm guessing her family is a christian
family muslim awesome that's interesting
muslim which is kind of interesting it's
a french movie
ah okay because because there are no
christians left in france yeah
it's all the only religious people are
the muslims yeah that would not have
come out of
america um you know the the
positive thing here is yeah there was
blow back they said you know
twerking 11 year olds is a little too
far
but the fact that that could make it
onto netflix with that poster with that
description
how did we get here it's not even goats
if i
you know if you had told me the goat
thing i'd say oh that's wholesome now
compared to cuties and i'm pretty sure
uh didn't rob schneider
bang a goat in an adam sandler movie
that would make sense yeah hopefully
i think if it was a movie yeah let's say
yeah it was a movie it's hollywood park
i saw him in bel air i don't remember um
yeah i mean nothing surprises me like
that that's what i'm saying
when i say there's a war on reality it's
like it's almost like we're getting
we're sort of in a boy who cried wolf
but it's but it's like more perverse
than that because it's almost like we
need
more shock value every day yeah to keep
us going and again that gets back to
that
that rat race thing it's like there is
we've dumbed this all down and we've
made it all so crazy
that i was reading you know one of the
things that i read over the last month i
read common sense by thomas paine
and a bunch of his other writings and
it's like i
was in the middle of one of the
paragraphs i stopped and i was like my
god
if a politician spoke like this yeah
three sentences in a row like this we'd
be like
he must be insane there's an insane
person here because
he was actually trying to talk about
honest things with common
sense right it's right in the title
right common sense i just get i mean i
i'm with you in that nothing surprises
me anymore yeah
you know if if i found as you say if i
found out coronavirus doesn't even exist
i'd say like huh
okay yeah i guess so whatever but it
just seemed to me like
kids you know that i you'd think that's
off limits but when you see the kind of
craziness
with shutting down the schools shutting
down you know the
the all of these kind of drag nine year
olds and whatever all these kind of
things
it has been building such that there are
no more taboos but the way you put it is
so right
which is you're in that hamster wheel
you got to get a little more you got to
go a little faster you've got to get
more
insanity yeah if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell